bit of breaking news we can bring you
Gary lineker is due to return to hosting
sport for the BBC Sky Sports News
understands it's understand that the
corporation will apologize to the match
of the day presenter it's unclear if he
will be back on air for the FA Cup
quarter-finals this weekend but a BBC
announcement is expected later today
let's talk to our correspondent Iva
Bennett who is outside the BBC this is
coming either from our colleagues at Sky
Sports News no independent confirmation
from the BBC yet but it looks like Mr
lenica might be getting an apology
yes I know quite a dramatic development
yet another in this story full of them
of course as you say this has come from
Sky Sports News and they understand that
Gary lineker will be returning to his
sport presenting duties here at the BBC
with as you say an apology being made
not from him to the BBC but instead from
the BBC the corporation to the presenter
himself so quite a an about turn uh in
terms of events where on Friday remember
it was the BBC who asked him told him to
step back from presenting duties after
he made that tweet remember that tweet
was made last Tuesday now it's been
going on this long that the original
tweet was him likening the language used
by the government to unveil their
strategy to tackle Small Boat Crossings
to that used by Germany in the 1930s
that then resulted in him being removed
from presenting duties a move that
clearly the BBC will now decide that
probably backfired because that resulted
in all the pundit team the presenting
team A Commentary team for match of the
Day stepping down walking out in
solidarity with lineker clearly the BBC
wants and to avoid a repeat of that and
now according to Sky Sports News we'll
be making this apology to Gary lineker
so that he can return to his presenting
duties this follows talks between the
two sides going on throughout the
weekend no independent confirmation from
the BBC yet I have been putting calls
into them repeatedly over the last 10-15
minutes since we heard this was about to
happen but nothing back yet will bring
it to you when we get that but we're not
we're not sure when linica will return
to the screen on BBC but we understand
it is imminent